Welcome to the MIT Center for
Art, Science & Technology's
2021 Symposium
"Unfolding Intelligence:
the Art and Science of
Contemporary Computation".
CAST was established
in 2012 with the goal
of building and
building on connections
between the worlds of art,
science, and technology.
This is the third in
a series of symposia
that CAST has
convened since then.
And as with its predecessors,
we bring together
artists, scientists, engineers,
and humanists from within MIT
and from the world
at large to discuss
areas of
rapidly-evolving research
and urgent social relevance.
And to find, in that dialogue,
stimulation, confirmation,
provocation, intersection,
and, we hope, common purpose.
At MIT, CAST partners with
departments, labs, and centers
to integrate the arts
across the curriculum,
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration, and to provide
support to faculty and
members of the MIT community
as they pursue their
own artistic practice
and/or research.
In addition to
symposia like this,
CAST facilitates the sharing
of this creative work
beyond the Institute
by producing concerts,
exhibitions, and
publications, and making
them available to the public.
So thank you for
being with us today.
We hope you will join
us throughout the week
at virtual events addressing
the aesthetic, technical,
and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media.
We also look forward to
seeing you on Friday,
April 9th as the
symposium culminates
with a live interactive
event to which
all attendees are invited.
And which you can join
presenters and artists
in breakout rooms to explore
hidden threads between all that
has been discussed this week.
Welcome to Unfolding
Intelligence, the Art
and Science of
Contemporary Computation.
Thank you for joining us and
for bringing your curiosity
and attention with you today.
Deep Time and Intelligence,
Unfolding Models, Open Systems,
Bias in AI--
even in this sheer,
titular variety
I hope you might hear whispers
of the ambitions afoot.
Could the discussion of
artificial intelligence
be reorganized by
the thoughts and work
of those who question AI, who
cautiously embrace and reshape
it to their needs and from
particular perspectives?
Those who work with and through
it, grounding our ideas about
and response to AI,
in such practices
that operate within the
orbit of these situated bases
of reflection.
Perhaps then, rather
than being strung along
by stories about inevitable
outcomes, impacts, and profits,
singularities, et
cetera, all reasoning
that assumes the essence
of AI is a sure thing,
that its effect on us and
our role in shaping it
are readily apprehensible
relations with a stable thing,
a predictable future.
Relieving ourselves of
that overexposure of AI
to intellectual
sureties, we may sense
a moment in which an instrument
of optimization and automation
becomes a medium open to
reuse and comment, tinkering,
and informed reflection, even a
generator of surprise results.
Deep Time and
Intelligence, the portion
of the discussion at hand.
In this panel, we
will see that AI
can help us to consider
fundamental questions about how
sensations, sounds, movements,
choreographies of form
and matter, take shape in
time, gain coherence as objects
and structures through training
and learning, recursion,
and iteration.
Deep time, yes, in terms
of the evolutionary time
scales at work in
growth and form
from the diatom to the social,
but also deep, as in downward,
to the nano and minute intervals
of the fold of a protein
or a crack in a crystal lattice.
AI seems to assist
us in traveling
to scales at which primordial,
logical formalisms operate
in dimensions and
through structures that
defy our concepts
and intuitions,
but perhaps not those
of feature detection
capacities exacting
computations can process.
Holly Herndon,
artist-composer-performer,
has built and conceptualized
for us a way of thinking music
in the context of a longue
durée of ritualized entertainment.
Gary Tomlinson,
Yale musicologist,
provides connections between
the story of evolution
and the unfolding of AI research
that few could account for,
given the myriad methods and
fields of research that he
has been able to synthesize,
building connections
between humanities
and sciences for us.
Markus Buehler, material
scientist here at MIT,
challenges us to think
of AI as something
capable of detecting
homologies of structure
across scales of existence,
perhaps even giving us
new ways of thinking about
universals across scales.
Antonio Torralba,
computer scientist
with CSAIL here at MIT,
moves not between scales
but across modes
of sensation, using
AI to link sound to vision
and movement to sound,
proposing a multimodal
sensory field for AI.
I shall withhold
any further attempt
at synthetic remarks at
present and listen now with you
all to the thoughts of
this wonderful group,
inviting you to listen with
me for hints of how AI might
be providing new insight
into form and structure,
cohering at divergent
length scales, time scales,
and between modalities
of sensation
and varying protocols
of entrainment.
It is important also now to
acknowledge that it is not
we the speakers nor MIT
who claim authority over
or seek final say regarding the
deep or any ultimate meaning
of ancient ancestry.
MIT acknowledges
Indigenous peoples
as the traditional
stewards of the land
and the enduring
relationship that
exists between them and their
traditional territories.
The land over which
circuits sustaining
MIT send their signals
to your screens
is the traditional
unceded territory
of the Wampanoag Nation.
We offer our
partial perspectives
in acknowledging that
we have much to learn,
and that an acknowledgment
such as this
is only a small first step
towards remembering and working
through the painful
histories of genocide
and forced occupation that
the Wampanoag Nation suffered,
land on which many diverse
Indigenous groups gathered
since time immemorial.
My name is William Lockett.
I'm the current
Mellon postdoctoral
fellow with the Center for
Art, Science, and Technology.
You'll see me at the Q&A,
leading the discussion
and also taking your
questions through Twitter.
Thank you and see you then.
Good morning,
afternoon, or evening.
Thank you for watching.
I'm Gary Tomlinson.
Provocative titles are
meant not merely to provoke,
but to draw us in.
And one of the more
compelling instances
I've come across recently is
this one from a 2020 article
by J. Mark Bishop, "Artificial
Intelligence is Stupid
and Causal Reasoning
Won't Fix It."
The essay opposes
computationalism,
the idea that human intelligence
is a strictly computational
affair, and it argues
that AI, since it
is a computational affair,
can't duplicate the feats
of human-like understanding.
Bishop's article is one
in a long line opposed
to computationalism, both as
an approach to the human brain
and as a way of making a
machine that might act like it.
And he takes us on a quick tour
of some of his predecessors,
from Godel's
incompleteness theorem,
as developed by John
Lucas and Roger Penrose,
to John Searle's
Chinese room, riffing
on the distinction
of formal syntax
from semantics, then building
on Hilary Putnam's idea
that all open systems are, in
effect, finite state automata.
Bishop reasons that equating
mind with computation leads
inevitably to pan-psychism, to
the assignment of mind to every
open system--to a
rock, for example.
What worries me about
much writing of this sort
is its proliferation
of key words
that are rarely defined as
clearly as they need to be.
Bishop's review runs
through a litany of them.
It's true that he mostly
avoids the vaguest terms, mind
and consciousness, but here
are some difficult words
he does rely on that
call out for unpacking
but receive little.
Understanding, as in the
human-like understanding
that automata don't achieve.
Or meaning, as in
the meaning of words
computational
machines can't grasp.
Other keywords that pop up
are synonyms for meaning.
Semantics and
content both appear
in Bishop's discussion of
Searle's Chinese room argument.
Two more difficult keywords
are experience and salience.
Is salience dependent on
experience or a part of it
or a generator of it?
What is experience, and how
does salience come about?
In this lexical thicket,
meaning is, for me,
the keyword of
keywords, and we can
expand the list of
closely related terms
beyond Searle's
content and semantics.
Reference, representation,
aboutness, intentionality, just
to give four examples.
In my remarks today,
I want to make
two observations about meaning
and its synonym cluster,
observations that seem to be
relevant to the possibilities
of a Strong AI or an
AGI, Artificial General
Intelligence.
The first observation
concerns the foundation
of meaning, which I
locate in semiosis,
that is, in sign making.
The theory I draw
on here is generally
humanistic in orientation.
The second observation
concerns the origins and extent
of the meaning that
arises from semiosis,
and here, my theoretical base
is in evolutionary science.
To look ahead,
these observations
will lead me toward a couple
of general caveats regarding
machine intelligence.
First, in order to see the
challenges of designing
a machine capable of
understanding meanings,
we need a firm grasp of the
nature of meaning itself.
This requires a
distinction that I
regard as fundamental and
ontological between information
transmission, a basic
process to all life forms,
and sign making, a particular
kind of information
transmission restricted
to a very small proportion
of those life forms.
Information transmission
of the first sort,
no matter how
powerful or elaborate,
can't lead to meaning,
content, or aboutness
because it can't create signs.
Only a machine capable
of semiotic information
could create or
understand meaning.
Second, once we see the
distinction between information
in general and the special
case of semiotic information,
we discern more clearly
the evolved capacities
that enable the creation of
science and hence, meaning.
These are not identifiable
traits possessed
by particular organisms,
not adaptations selected
for particular functions.
Such selection-for is not
how natural selection works.
It's not an
optimization problem,
notwithstanding Dan
Dennett's decades-long effort
to make us think it is.
The capacities to create
meaning are instead
ongoing processes of negotiation
with an external world,
and so they can't be identified
as discrete properties
of an organism.
Processes, not properties.
This is a motto that
should hang above the door
of every evolutionist.
It already hangs above
the doors of many.
These processes are signaled
in the "radical niche
construction" of my title.
OK, so much for looking ahead.
Let's start with the distinction
of non-semiotic and semiotic
information.
The first could be called
information, pure and simple,
or Shannon information, but
I'll call it causal information,
since it's a matter
of causal covariance,
as Jerry Fodor once put it.
Its transmission along
some kind of channel
brings about some corresponding
effect at the receiving end.
Information of this sort
is a relational thing.
The channels can feed back
from receiver to sender.
They can be networked in
parallel and serial fashion,
doubled and redoubled again,
and hierarchized in any number
of routines and subroutines.
But the fundamental
relationality of covariance
remains.
All living things, even
the simplest bacterium,
are complex miracles of this
kind of information processing,
but their information in the
vast majority of organisms
is not about anything.
It's without content or
meaning, a sheer causality that
makes things happen from the
molecular level on up in scale
through organismal and
ecosystemic levels.
It brings about
correlated difference
in the complex systems that
work at all these levels.
Semiotic information
is something different
that arises on the foundation
of causal information.
It depends not on
systems of relations
alone, but on a relation to
a regulation, a metarelation.
This requires something more
complex than the Shannon
model of transmitter
channel and receiver
and something different
even from the idea
of a hierarchy of routines.
It requires
something so complex,
in fact, that it
has emerged only
in a tiny percentage of the life
forms our biosphere has known.
While all life
forms are processors
of causal information,
very few are creators
of semiotic information.
This basic distinction of
causal and semiotic information
is relevant to the
question of meaning
because meaning is founded
in the sign metarelation.
Signs are always signs of.
They introduce
aboutness in the world
by virtue of this fundamental
nature, introducing
at the same time what we connote
by all the synonyms named
above: content,
semantics, and so forth.
Signs are representational
in the exact sense
of re-presenting one
thing in another.
This is what signs do.
It's not what causal
information does.
Signs are not the same
as signals in the way
this word is loosely but
pervasively used by biologists.
A signal is non-semiotic
and usually comes
down to a threshold
mechanism in the operation
of causal information.
It doesn't re-present
one thing in another.
A metarelation is required
for semiosis most basically
because a sign is something
different than a cause
of its object.
It is instead an
analysis of its object.
It divides up the
object, picking out
certain aspects of it to
use in re-presenting it,
its complexity
constrained in the picking
both by its own nature and
by the nature of the object.
Signs and their objects
never mesh completely.
That would collapse the
sign into the object,
collapsing at the same
time aboutness and content.
There's no re-presenting
in identity.
But what is it that enters
into this complex relation
between aspects of one entity
and aspects of another?
What is the added something
that creates the metarelation?
This is a third entity,
one capable of forming
percepts of certain sorts.
It doesn't exercise sovereign
control over these percepts.
Instead, it's called into
the aspectual constraints
of what will become sign and
object, called by their nature
as affordances in the world.
Its percepts are always formed
not only by its own capacities,
but also by the entities that
come to form sign and object.
Semiosis is, in
this way, a process
of reciprocal constraint,
reciprocal affordance,
if you'd like, among a percept
and things or phenomena
external to it.
It's a niche-constructive
process.
Those of you familiar with the
philosophy of Charles Sanders
Peirce will recognize
in this approach
to semiotics two
basic Peircan tenets.
The first is the
partial aspectual nature
of all the relations in
the sign making process.
From his scrutiny
of this partiality,
viewed in its many
combinatorial possibilities,
sprang the many typologies of
science that Peirce offered.
The second tenet is the
calling of a perceiver
into the aspectual
parsing of the world,
an idea for which Perice
coined the term interpretant.
This is a fundamental term
in his philosophy but one
that has been much
misunderstood.
It involves no interpretation,
as we tend to use that word,
but relies instead on
the perceptual capacity
to divide up the world,
to parse it, as I've said,
registering some of its parts,
clumping some things together
with others and relating
itself to those relations.
How do some life forms come to
be able to form interpretants?
Memory is crucial,
but not merely
the simplest forms of
storage and retrieval.
Instead, something like an
episodic memory is necessary,
a mechanism that can
retrieve memories
as parts of whole
situations, retrieve them
more readily because
of those situations
and enrich and relive the
situations in the retrieval.
Some animals besides
humans are capable
of such episodic memory.
Most animals, and all
other organisms, are not.
Learning is also central, but
learning of an advanced sort
dependent on episodic memory.
Simple associative learning
is a purely relational thing
and occurs in many,
many creatures
without any semiosis as a
function of simple neural nets
involving excitation
and inhibition connected
with the innate reward
or punishment signals.
A well-studied example is
the sucrose sensitivity
of honeybees on the
basis of which they
learn complex
associations concerning
food sources and much else.
This is non-semiotic learning.
On the other hand, the
learning of a songbird,
for example, to rank
the varied challenges
from the songs of its
neighbors or to sing by itself
a pseudo-duet suggesting
to other birds
that its mate is
present when it's not,
these are semiotic
through and through.
They depend in each case on
the retrieval and processing
of whole episodes
from a bird's life.
And from these,
they parse aspects
that conduce to
interpretant formation.
Memory, learning, and
finally attention.
Attention is a
more basic capacity
than memory or learning.
And it too comes in more
and less complex forms.
It's related even in
its simplest forms
to the salience I mentioned
before, the way an organism
can single out a particular
stimulus from all those
coming to it.
The sensitivity of
honeybees to sucrose again
provides a good example.
For semiosis, a more
complex attentional capacity
is required, one that can
sustain a recursive analysis
of incoming stimuli, taking
them apart into their aspects
and focusing on them at both
comprehensive and partial
levels.
In this analytic or
parsing function,
attention enables
the construction
of episodes in
memory and learning,
building memories as aspects
of broader situations.
Studies of such
complex attention
suggests that it's the product
of mediations of information
in which salience filters
proximate to sensory input
interface with further
processing and modulation
downstream.
Interface, that is,
with top-down systems
higher up in the
midbrain and forebrain.
Such neural mediations
are, I think, fundamental
to the emergence of
semiotic information,
and I'll touch on
them again later.
Attention, memory, learning,
these foundations for semiosis
are not, as I said before,
discrete properties
of certain animals, but instead
processes in their engagements
with their niches.
Recognizing the flexible
complexity of these processes
is what has recently
radicalized the ideas of niche
construction.
Let's step back for a moment.
In general, niche
construction refers
to the reciprocal or feedback
process by which organisms
build their selective
environments
as those environments
build them.
This construction has
tended to be thought
of as a dynamic operating
across long timescales
with environments and
populations of organisms
slowly shifting in
tandem with one another.
The ancestors of
beavers, for example,
gradually adapting
to aquatic life
even as their behavior has
created more and more aquatic
environments.
Alterations in the niche
brought about by organisms
bring about shifting
selective dynamics, which
eventually alter the
genomes of those organisms.
Now, what I'm
terming radical niche
construction
involves recognizing
the pervasive plasticity of
niche constructive feedback
across all biotic scales
of time and space.
We now see that
niche construction
is not only a long-term
process but also
the plastic responsiveness of
all organisms to their changing
environments operating
at a much quicker pace.
Natural selection has resulted
not in fixed capacities
with discrete
advantageous functions
so much as in the flexibility
by which the nodal systems that
make up organisms open
out to myriad aspects
of their environments.
And, this is most
important, this plasticity
reaches from the
niche all the way
to genes, which turn out to
be nothing like blueprints
for life forms, but instead
are open information systems
in constant flux with the
situations around them.
An example can come once
again from honeybees.
Dozens of pheromones are crucial
in the intricate regulation
of the honeybee colony
or superorganism.
They're produced of
course by individual bees,
according to complex
bioinformational pathways
involving genes, RNA
transcription of various sorts,
proteins that genes
construct, and more.
But the pathways run
in both directions.
The genetic instructions
are regulated
by the proteins they produce,
which in turn are regulated
by the external circulation
of the pheromones
they help to produce.
Brief exposure to
a single chemical
in the cocktail that functions
as an alarm pheromone
alters factors inducing
RNA transcription
in the olfactory centers
of the bee brain,
allowing genes to
be expressed that
activate fight or
flight and aggression
pathways in higher
brain regions, which
then modulate bee behavior.
An hour after such exposure, the
resulting information cascades
have up- or down-regulated
the expression
of hundreds of genes,
laying a foundation
for heightened responsiveness
to subsequent alarms.
The whole network, extending
from niche to genes,
has been altered in the blink of
an eye or the whiff of a scent.
Similar cascades
regulate, it is now clear,
the genomic expression
of all life forms.
With such radical niche
construction in mind,
let's return to
semiosis and ask where
we might seek neural
substrates for the interpretant
and the metarelation.
I think we need to
seek them not simply
in the redoubling of parallel
processing in large brains,
and not even only in
the serial extension
in such brains of
processing along
a sequence of distinct
modules, though both of these
will probably play a role.
An additional element
of neural architecture
is built on top of these,
bringing massive parallelism
and serialism to bear in
modulating the processing
of other connected centers.
Instead of peripheral sensory
neurons connecting directly
to the highest
processing centers,
large vertebrate
brains have processors
connected to processors,
all reconnected
in loops of feedback systems.
The song system in a songbird's
brain provides an example.
This is often divided
into three systems, two
pathways controlling song
learning, song learning
memorization, and production,
and a third pathway
for auditory production,
auditory processing.
The slide I'm showing
you divides these
into two sagittal
sections of the brain
with the vocal
pathways on the left
and the auditory
pathway on the right.
It's easy to see that
the systems are networked
in immensely complex ways
involving many nuclei, each
with large numbers of neurons.
The auditory nuclei are linked
to the song control ones,
thinking left- and right-hand
diagrams, in other words,
and bringing audition directly
to bear on memory and learning.
Especially important for
the semiotic complexity
of birdsong, I think,
is the mediating role
of the thalamus in
these networks, situated
between mid- and hindbrain,
and higher cognitive functions.
Notice that it
doesn't merely relay
processed sensory input
to higher brain regions
but is a part of loops
from those regions
involved in both song
production and audition.
In mammals, the thalamus is a
midbrain processing station,
mediating top-down and
bottom-up networks.
It's implicated in attentional
focus, voluntary motor
behavior, memory, and
learning, and so it
seems to be in songbirds.
There's nothing nearly as
elaborated as these networks
in the brain of a honeybee.
Here, by contrast, is a
diagram of the network
for sucrose sensitivity
and responses
that I mentioned before.
The relevant part
of this diagram
is the red arrow tracing
a single long neuron that
projects from the proboscis
through the antennal lobes
to higher brain regions, the
so-called mushroom bodies,
and to the green
motor control center.
The complexity built into this
tiny brain is truly awesome,
but it's far outstripped by
the bird brain's multiplicity
of distinct modules,
their serial and parallel
connections, and their
intricate feedback mediation
through distinct
levels of processing.
It's not merely the complexity
of neural architecture,
however, that brings about
the cognitive functions
of interpretant
sign and meaning.
To achieve this, we need to
set this network in motion
as a process rather
than an architecture.
And the motion
comes about through
the radical
niche-constructed plasticity
in the face of
changing affordances
I spoke about before.
The informational complexities
I exemplified with the alarm
pheromones of bees
altering gene expression
on a moment-to-moment basis are
at work in all animal brains
and extensively
studied in songbirds.
They seem to foster a varied and
complex processing of the world
proportionate to the varied
complexity of the brain
architectures they enliven.
It's from this, I
think, that a new fold
is introduced into the
experience of certain animals.
From this, that they
gain the parsing power
that makes their percepts
analytic and at the same time
opens those percepts to
the formative rebound
from the things they
analyze, the calling
into the interpretant.
From this fold, this
recursive percept,
arises the cognizance of
a relation in perception
to a relation of things in the
world, the essence of the sign
and meaning.
Let's return finally to
the challenges facing
the project of an AI that
could construct and understand
meaning.
What should be apparent
from my quick overview
of the foundations of
animal meanings first
is the wild over-optimism
of Rodney Brooks's assertion
around 1990 that his robots
were approximating even
insect levels of intelligence.
The complexities of
bee behavior depend
on modest attention,
memory, and learning, all
rendered processual and
reactive to the changing world
by systems of gene
regulations linked
through cellular pathways
out to external stimuli.
In insects, these are all causal
informational complexities.
They do not manifest
the metarelation
or create semiotic information.
So the first step in
making a thinking machine
would be to come somewhere
close to the complexities
of radical niche
construction evident,
even in non-semiotic creatures,
complexities that are still
not fully appreciated 30 years
after Rodney Brooks's embedded,
embodied, and situated AI.
This would give
robots an ability
to react to their
environments in ways
that resemble the plastic
genomic shifts of living
organisms.
This is a very high bar
for machinic intelligence.
Even surpassing it, however,
wouldn't endow a machine
with the ability to create
aboutness and meaning.
For this further leap, we'd need
to marshal systems of systems
of the sort exemplified
by our songbird
and then harness them to the
plastic capacity animals show
to remake the systems in
moment-to-moment negotiation
with their niches.
The machine would need
complex attentional capacities
meshing high- and
low-level processing.
It would need episodic memory,
recalling whole situations
in its past, and shaping its
learning on the basis of them.
And all these systems would
need to submit themselves
to a ceaseless alteration
on every scale,
starting from the
smallest generative
ones, the genes in the
machine, so to speak,
which could not be
conceived as fixed entities.
Now, I'm not an expert in AI or
indeed any kind of computation.
My only programming experience
was a course in BASIC
I took 50 years ago
at Dartmouth College,
taught, as I remember it,
by John Kemeny himself,
or perhaps he only
visited the class,
leaving its day-to-day operation
to his graduate students.
But I pose the question to
those who do know about AI,
are we coming close to all this?
Can all the evolutionary
algorithms, deep learning,
and metaheuristics
of today's AI begin
to glimpse the lifeways
of animals that bring
about meaning in the world?
Can they approach even
a lesser standard,
the autopoietic
intelligence of a honeybee?
Thank you very much.
Hi, my name is Holly Herndon.
I'm a composer and artist
based in Berlin working largely
with music and technology.
I'll start this talk with a
little background about my work
and then I'll talk about my
most recent project, Proto,
where I'm incorporating
machine learning.
So Movement was my first
album released in 2012.
And for this album I built
custom digital processes
for vocal performance
really in search
of an embodied electronic
music performance practice.
And around that time I was
coming to the conclusion
that the laptop is the most
intimate instrument I have ever
known.
And at the time it
was still somewhat
controversial to see
laptops in the concert hall
as a concert instrument, so by
introducing the processed voice
it created a kind of bridge
to traditional performance
practice.
I released Platform in
2015 as my second album
and I worked with Mat Dryhurst
and Metahaven on that project.
Around that time I was
coming to the conclusion
that if the laptop was my
primary instrument, then
the internet was really
an extended part of that.
I began to focus on the
mediated relationships
that I was having online.
And I started making
music from sampling
my own online activities.
Around that time
I was also touring
rather extensively off the back
of my first album, Movement.
And I began to feel
like I was more at home
with my email inbox than
necessarily my apartment
that I would barely even see.
And so in the wake of Edward
Snowden's allegations,
I realized that a lot of
those really private moments
and gestures might not
be so private in the end.
And that every gesture made
online might hypothetically
be considered a performance
for an unannounced observer.
So the intimacy I had
established with Movement
felt compromised or violated.
But for me there was really
no turning back at that point.
It already was my
primary instrument,
so I really needed to understand
what this new paradigm meant
for the art form.
The album Proto was
released in 2019
and I'm going to spend a little
bit of time talking about that
and the work that led to
that I've been focusing
on the last couple years.
When I first started working
with machine learning
I was looking into
the history a bit
and I found several
examples of people creating
automated composition machines.
So that's this idea of training
a machine learning algorithm
on Bach and then receiving
infinite variations of Bach.
But I also came across
a different perspective
on machine learning,
a different approach
when I learned about George
Lewis and his Voyager
project, which was developed
in the late '80s and early '90s
at IRCAM.
And so Lewis was
attempting to create
a kind of ensemble member that
he could improvise alongside.
So rather than
seeing the machine
learning tool as a replacement
to himself as a composer,
he rather saw this as
an augmentation or a way
that he could perform
alongside a machine learning
algorithm, which I found really
interesting and inspiring.
So he was trying to embed
the musical decisions
and aesthetics of the community
that he was surrounded
with through the AACM and
a lot of the improv scene
in African-American
circles in Chicago.
And he was trying to embed
a lot of the aesthetics
from this specific community
into the Voyager system.
And I really love
that his work really
acknowledges that aesthetics
and musical decisions
actually come from somewhere.
They're human cultural
decisions that
come from humans interacting
with one another musically
in space together.
So this is our machine
learning project
that we named Spawn and
this is her cover debut
and her birthday
is listed as 2017.
And the reason why
we use this metaphor
of a baby, of an inhuman
baby, of an early life,
we found this metaphor really
useful in that Spawn really
only has access
to the information
that we as a community
give her and really
foster her with the data
that we're feeding her.
So we found this as a
way to not only talk
about the importance
of her daily diet,
but also the communal
nature in raising
this nascent intelligence.
Early on, we decided to work
with audio rather than MIDI
files--
MIDI is a Machine
Legible Musical Score,
for a few primary reasons.
For one thing MIDI score loses
a lot of the performance detail
that audio captures.
So certain timbral and
performance expressions
are really difficult to
capture in a MIDI file.
Also, we didn't want to use
actual scores from the past,
from ourselves or from
others, as it would encourage
us to make similar
compositional decisions, rather
than new decisions responding
to the world around us.
We view composition as a
living, breathing art form.
And we feared that if
we trained on past work,
we might find ourselves
in an aesthetic cul-de-sac
where we're just recreating
musical decisions of the past.
And lastly, we also
wanted to use our own data
that we could compensate
people and give credit for.
So we created all of
our own data sets.
There's a lot of
entitlement happening
in the field of
machine learning when
it comes to using other people's
data, our shared human archive.
And so I'll speak about
that a little bit later,
but it was really
important to us
that we were able to
create our own data sets.
So this is an early example
that was trained on my speaking
voice and I'm using a recurrent
neural network for this.
[DIGITALLY ALTERED SPEECH]
I love how rough and imperfect
that early experiment was.
So this led to Godmother where
it sounds like Spawn's almost
beatboxing this music.
Which is really funny,
because I didn't actually
train the model to beatbox.
But there was spoken word and
sung passages and, of course,
when those two combine that
creates a kind of beatboxing.
And already you can kind of hear
that Spawn can outperform me
in many ways.
There's no limit on the
pitch range of Spawn.
I really see this as building
on some of my early experiments
with digital vocal
processing, which was really
a way for me to transcend some
of the physical limitations
of my body.
And this, for me, was
the next step in that.
So to be able to create a
voice model of my own voice
which didn't really have to
adhere to the laws of physics
of my own body.
[DIGITAL VOCALIZING]
So parallel to my
work developing Spawn,
I was also working with a
vocal ensemble in Berlin.
Much in the lineage
of George Lewis,
we decided to work with
Spawn as an ensemble member.
Training her on various
members' voices,
so she could perform certain
parts that we composed
alongside the ensemble.
So you can see her sitting on
top of the piano for this group
shot.
And this is about
half of the ensemble.
There's around 10
members in total.
As these worlds came
together, I started
thinking about machine learning
as a human coordination
technology.
Seeing parallels to early
folk vocal techniques
developed for group coordination
or cultural cohesion
and ritual.
And all of a sudden, a
singing AI ensemble member
made perfect sense.
Our ultimate goal is
to be able to perform
with our machine
learning system live,
but we're not quite there yet.
Everything that we
recorded for the album
required rendering
time that just
wasn't capable of a real
time, low latency performance.
So we found a way to
include a machine learning
aspect to our live performances
without having that real time
system.
We decided to
invite the audience
to train Spawn in a kind of call
and response with our ensemble.
And we're really
trying to communicate
that as soon as a gesture
is captured in media, photo,
video, audio, whatever, it
can become machine legible
and can then be part
of a training canon.
We have recordings from our
audiences all over the world,
so we're able to create unique
crowd models for each audience
that we visit.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Our fears.
Our fears.
The faith will .
That's why we sing.
Emergent life.
Appears.
Beautiful, thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is really a
huge topic to condense
into such a short
talk, but I want
to briefly touch on some of
the questions and ideas that
arose around machine
learning and music.
And I find it useful to look
at sampling as a precursor.
This is an image of
Pierre Schaeffer,
who's often credited as an early
pioneer of musique concrète,
which was an early
recording and sampling.
And Schaeffer had a
unique for the time
opinion on how people might
listen to sounds decoupled
from their sound source.
So, for example, if you listen
to the sound of a train,
the elevated listener,
in Schaeffer's mind,
might be able to just think
about the aesthetic properties
and the sonic qualities
of that train sound
without actually imagining
the train itself.
And while this is a really
interesting concept,
when we apply that same idea
to human-made musical gestures,
such as instrumental music or
vocal music, human created,
when we decontextualized
the sound
from its source we also
erase the people who
made those original
sounds, we take away
the accreditation component.
And while sampling led to
incredible new genres of music,
from hip hop to
electronica, history
is often told by the victors.
And there were also some
pretty egregious examples
where people's work was
used and widely distributed
and it was never compensated.
So one of these failures
of copyright law
is GC Coleman's drum break from
the 1969 song "Amen, Brother."
It's probably the most
sampled drum beat in history.
I'm going to play
this in a minute
and if you're familiar with
genres such as breakbeat
or drum and bass, this is the
essential rhythmic foundation
of these entire
genres that went on
to sell hundreds of
thousands of records
and inspire musicians
across the world.
And unfortunately, Coleman,
when he passed away he
was homeless and was unaware
of the success of his sample
and was never compensated
for that work.
[MUSIC - GC COLEMAN, "AMEN BROTHER"]
[DRUM SOLO]
So the question is, how do we
not repeat those same mistakes
of the past?
This led me to think about this
concept of vocal sovereignty.
So what does it mean
to own one's own voice?
And there are a few
court cases that are
interesting to reference here.
For one, Bette Midler was
approached by Mercury Sable
to license one of her
songs for a commercial
and she rejected them, so they
hired a Bette Midler sing-alike
and she was actually able
to successfully sue them
that they had infringed
on her vocal likeness.
And I'll just play
a quick example,
so you can hear how her
vocal articulation was really
mimicked by the
vocal sing-alike.
MUSIC - "DO YOU WANT TO DANCE"]
(SINGING) Do you want to
dance and hold my hand?
Tell me you're my lover man.
Do you want to dance
and hold my hand?
Now, there's a car that
just asks to be driven.
Tell me you're my lover.
So thinking about these voice
models and vocal likeness,
vocal sovereignty, made
me ask a few questions.
What is an authentic
voice and who owns it?
What role does influence,
inspiration, and appropriation
have?
How might we deal
with influence when
it's automated and
can no longer operate
under the alibi of inspiration?
Or can a machine, in
fact, be inspired?
How do styles evolve over
time and what's the best way
to acknowledge influence?
This slide isn't intended
to flatten these influence
relationships,
but rather to show
that influence comes
in different forms
across generations.
Not all influence
relationships are the same.
What does it mean
if these influences
can become fully automated?
Nina Sun Eidsheim writes
in The Race of Sound:
Listening, Timbre, and Vocality
in African-American Music,
"voice is not singular,
it's collective.
Voice is not innate,
it's cultural."
She goes on to clarify,
singing is always
made up of entrainment,
style, and technique,
but is generally
mistaken for essence.
So the voice is communal and
we perform as individuals
through it.
So with the history
of sampling in mind,
we came up with this
idea of "spawning."
How might machine learning
tools address some of the issues
that sampling caused
in the last century?
How might we build
in better systems
from the beginning
to help avoid some
of the pitfalls of the past?
The idea that we came up with
we like to call "spawning."
So individuals sample others
with no hard coded attribution,
that's sampling.
Spawning attributes
and builds upon source,
or at least it could.
Individuals sample others
with no hard coded payment.
Spawning pays at source.
Sampling repeats
expressions from the past.
Spawning build's variations
from past expressions.
Sampling is one-to-one
reproduction.
Spawning a smart
and reproductive.
Given the enormous capabilities
and possibilities of machine
learning models and
some of the questions
I brought up around
vocal sovereignty,
we think it's important to be
thinking about these issues
from the start.
One idea I've been developing
is called "Hitmaker,"
and it's a project in
collaboration with JJ
Burred and Mathew Dryhurst.
And so this is a
contemporary take
on a sampler using
machine learning.
So the idea is is
you have a source,
and then as soon as you load
that source into the tool
it's registered, so it
can be automatically given
attribution.
And then the next step
leads to a sound separation
and spawning, which I'll
demonstrate briefly here.
[MUSIC - "HITMAKER"]
[VOCALIZING]
So first we separate the
kick and the snare sound
using a sound
separation algorithm.
[DRUM BEATS]
And using those
as a target sound,
we're able to spawn or
create new variations
on those original sounds.
[DRUM BEATS]
So we're obviously working with
very simple percussive sounds
in this instance,
but you could imagine
how one might extrapolate
other instrument
sounds from an original source.
This is another
project that we're
working on using Google
Magenta's DDSP system, which
can transfer timbre from
one instrument to another.
We're currently trying to make
the system work for real time
performance.
This is an example of a voice
being transformed into a flute.
This is a collaboration I worked
on with Maria Arnal, who's
a Catalan vocalist, and this is
the "Song of Sybil" a cappella.
And then I'll play
the flute version.
So pay close attention to
the ornaments in her vocal
and see how closely they
align with the flute version.
[MUSIC - MARIA ARNAL, "SONG OF SYBIL"]
[VOCALIZING]
[FLUTE INSTRUMENTAL]
And lastly, I'm working on
an opensource model version
of my voice that I'll be
able to share with the wider
public in about a month.
Unfortunately, I can't
share that yet at this time,
but I'm really excited
to-- for that to come out,
so please stay tuned for that.
For those who are interested,
some of the questions
that came up through the
making of this last album
and some of the new tools that
we're developing at the moment,
I discuss these issues
on a weekly basis
with my partner, Mat Dryhurst,
on our podcast Interdependence.
The idea is that we're
speaking with people
who we think are shaping
21st century culture, often
with a focus on the
impact of technology.
Thank you so much for your time.
Our visual system is amazing.
We can make sense of
the world around us
just by analyzing the light that
bounces off objects and reaches
our eyes.
To illustrate this, let
me show you a movie.
This will help you to
appreciate how amazing we are.
This following video is
showing a very low quality
movie recorded in my office.
This movie is so blurry
that many of the objects
are defined by only
one single pixel.
But our visual
system is so amazing
that we can recognize a
person talking on the phone,
listening to some music,
and working on a computer.
And it is amazing that
we are able to recognize
so much from so little
visual information.
Of course, most of what
we saw in this video
was not really there.
Most of what we saw in the
video was only inside our heads.
And to illustrate
this, let's watch
the original high
resolution movie.
As you can see now,
many of the objects
that you recognized before were
not really what you thought.
So why is it so difficult
to build a machine that sees
the same ways that humans do?
Well, the input to a
vision system, an image,
is just a collection of numbers
like the one shown here.
Its number represents a pixel
intensity at that location.
The numbers do not
directly tell us
which objects are
in the picture,
or even which numbers
are part of an object
or part of the background.
This is what a machine will see.
And what we see here, if
we look at the same numbers
but displayed in the
form of a picture,
that we see just a blurry
picture of a person walking.
Computer vision systems need
to be designed and trained
to see the person
behind the numbers.
And that's where the
challenge resides.
Training a system capable of
recognizing objects and images
generally requires
annotating manually
thousands of images
where we will
have to indicate
what are the objects
in each picture,
their boundaries,
and what their name is.
And the system will then
learn to associate the image
with the annotations
that we provided.
And this process is
very labor intensive,
and it requires many hundreds
of hours of manual labor.
A different strategy that is
currently used in research
is to train systems
using computer graphics.
So for instance, the community
is developing virtual worlds
where you can interact with
agents, you can see the world,
recognize objects,
and train AI systems
in these environments
with the hope
that later they will learn
something that can be
transferred to the real world.
But all these different
ways of training
artificial visual
systems are very
different to how babies actually
learn to perceive the world.
And so let's watch a
baby actually learning
to recognize things
in the world.
A baby learns most of
the time by itself.
There is no supervision
from the parents.
There are no labels.
And he learns by
interacting with the world,
by looking at things, by hearing
the noise that they make,
by touching them, and
finally, tasting them.
And a baby will learn
to discover objects,
to understand materials,
to perceive a space,
to manipulate objects
via interaction.
And it will do this
through a very rich set
of sensory modalities--
vision, audition, smell, taste,
and touch.
And he does this in a
completely unsupervised way.
It doesn't require the type
of exhaustive annotations
that current AI systems need
to learn about the world.
So in this presentation,
I will describe
some of the work in our
groups, trying to build systems
that leverage different sensory
modalities to learn to perceive
the world without supervision.
So we started our work in 2016
with a very simple set in.
Andrew Owens, a
PhD student at MIT,
recorded video and sounds
while he was hitting surfaces
with a drumstick.
For about a month,
he walked around
with the camera and a
drumstick and recorded
many thousands of hits.
So let me show some
of his greatest hits.
He hit and scratched
surfaces all over MIT
for a long, long time.
And he recorded tens of
thousands of these events.
So with this data set, we
asked the following question.
Given the video input
without the audio--
just the pixels-- is
it possible to predict
what the audio should be?
So we want to build a system
that will take this input--
just the pixels, just
the frames of the video--
and it should produce the
sounds that should go with it.
A system trained to solve
this audio prediction task
should be able to solve
the following problems.
It will have to
recognize the drumstick.
And it will have
to detect when it
is in contact with the
surface and whether it
was a hit or a scratch.
It will have to recognize
the type of contact--
the strength and the
duration of the contact.
It will have to
recognize the material
where the contact happened.
And finally, it will have
to associate all of this
with the sounds that you hear.
So we did that task.
We trained a system
to solve this problem.
And what I will show
you now is the result
of running that system
on a silent video.
So what you will
see, the input video,
shows the drumstick hitting
and scratching a rock.
But the system will only see
the images, not the audio.
What you will hear,
as I play this video,
is the audio predicted
by the system.
It's not the real audio
that came with the video.
So let's play this.
And as you can hear,
the sound was currently,
temporarily aligned with the
moments in which the drumstick
was in contact with the surface,
and the sounds corresponded
to hits and scratches.
It was not perfect.
But the system shows that
it has learned something
about the vessel
and other worlds
without any human supervision
So what has the system learned?
The network has learned to
represent surface properties
from visual information only.
That allows to discriminate
among different types
of materials.
A simple classifier trained
on the self-learned features
can discriminate among
different types of materials.
It will confuse materials that
produce similar sounds when
hit with a drumstick, such
as glass and metal, which
sound very similar when you
hit them with a drumstick.
But learning with
sounds and images
can be done even without
having to hit everything
with a drumstick.
In fact, when we are
in a particular place,
anywhere, we will
always hear some sounds.
The ambient sound
that surrounds us
is a mixture of
all of the sounds
that are made by the objects
that are present in the scene.
So it's like thinking
that the world comes
with its own soundtrack.
And many objects in the
world produce sounds
by themselves of
different kinds.
And the main cue that
we could use here
is the temporal coincidence
of hearing a particular sound
and seeing a particular
visual pattern in the world.
And then we can
create an association
between that sound that we
hear and that particular visual
pattern and the
fact that they seem
to co-occur time over time.
So we can now play the same
crush model prediction game
that we did for the drumstick.
We will try to predict
what type of sounds
are associated with
a particular image.
And in this case, the image
will not contain the drumstick.
It's just whatever
objects are there
that are producing sounds.
And a model trained to solve
this task, if it is successful,
it will have to solve
the following problem.
It will have to be able to
recognize and categorize
the objects that are in the
scene that are naturally
associated with ambient sounds.
And it will have
to associate them
with the appropriate
type of sound that
goes with that object.
So what has a network
like that learned?
We can now, once we
train such a system,
we can look inside what
the system has learned.
Just in a similar way to
how a neuroscientist would
look inside the brain--
look at the activation
of the neurons
to try to understand
how the brain works--
we can perform the same thing
on a neural network that has
been trying to solve this task.
And what we discover is
that inside the network,
some of the neurons
became specialized
in detecting baby faces or
those units became specialized
in detecting crowds of people.
And this is because baby faces--
babies produce a
particular type of sound.
And whenever a baby
face was present,
that was the sound that
was associated with it.
Crowds also made a
different type of noise.
And there are other
units that are selected
to waterfalls, the ocean.
And all of those
units have learned
to detect objects
in images that are
associated with distinctive
types of sounds.
There are units that
will detect also
the sky because it comes
with the sound of the wind.
And also, cars.
The important point
here is that these units
have learned to
detect these objects,
without acquiring any
type of human supervision,
just by learning from
the temporal association
between sounds and
visual patterns.
In particular, for instance,
the car selective unit
is capable of detecting
cars, but it has never
been trained with a human having
to annotate cars in images.
Sensing images and audio
has a long history.
But there are other types of
sensitive sensory modalities.
And in particular, one very
important sensory modality
for humans, for which there does
not exist a mature technology,
is touch.
Tactile information is
essential for humans,
with a significant
part of our brains
the ability to process
tactile information recorded
by our skin.
And there are a
number of devices--
commercial devices
and research devices--
that have developed to
measure tactile information.
But it is still a
very small number.
Those devices are nowhere
near the quality of maturity
that cameras and
microphones have reached.
We are developing
tactile sensors
that will also record tactile
information when a human
interacts with an object.
In this particular
case, it's a glove
that a human can wear that
records pressure signals.
And as you are
manipulating an object,
it will record which
parts of the hand
are in contact with
the object and what is
the strength of that contact.
This way, we can
develop approaches
that can use this measured
tactile information to perform
object recognition, to measure
object properties, and so on.
And it's not just
about the hand.
The same technology
can be extended
to cover large body
surfaces, and eventually
become a tactile-sensing
skin for robots.
So as I mentioned, all these
different sensory modalities
is what provides,
now, a way of learning
from the temporal coincidences
between different events
across different senses.
And this will provide a
method to learn about objects
without requiring
human annotations.
Besides interacting
with the world,
there are many
other ways in which
we learn to recognize things.
So let's think of
the following game.
Let's say that I give
you lots of images,
and you have to play
the following game.
Given a collection
of images, I want
you to draw a new image that
looks similar to the images
that I gave you.
It doesn't need to be one of
the images that I gave you,
but it has to look as
belonging to the same family.
Playing this game
requires understanding
what the content of
these pictures is,
understanding
through the geometry,
and then drawing something
that looks similar to it.
And current systems--
current neural networks
have been tackling this
problem for some time.
And there has been a lot of
progress in recent years.
There is a family
of systems called
generative adversarial networks
that try to solve that problem.
Given a bunch of
images, they want
to be able to draw new
images that look real.
This approach was
proposed in 2014,
and these are the
type of images that
were produced by an artificial
system trying to reproduce
images that seem real.
And as you can see, they
were very low quality--
very similar to the blurry
movie that I showed you
at the beginning.
Two years later,
new advances were
capable of drawing
images like the ones
that I'm showing here, which are
trying to look like bedrooms.
They are not very
good, but you can
see that there has been
a big step forward.
And there are some
geometric figures
that look like they could
come from the real world.
Although, no one
would get will get
fooled in thinking that
these are real images.
But just two years
later, the advances
were so big that systems
were capable of producing
images that looked like this
and therefore quite real.
And since then, there has
been a lot of progress.
So the system, what
it does is start
with a collection of
images like these ones
that contains buildings,
churches, and castles.
And from this
collection, it will
train to be able to generate new
images that should look real.
The way in which this
neural network works is it
will take as input
just a random number--
a random collection of
numbers, like flipping
a coin 512, 500, times--
and recording just the outcomes.
This vector will enter
into a neural network that
will recombine this set of
numbers, make it bigger,
recombine again, enhance it,
recombine it, until at the end,
you end up with a picture.
And this picture is a
randomly generated image.
If you throw the coin multiple
times, different times,
you will get a
different set of images.
So these are examples of images
that are not real images.
They are generated by
this neural network,
and they look amazing.
They even have
watermarks because they
were part of the trainings.
But the question is, to render
images that look so real,
what is it this neural
network has really learned?
Does it know about objects?
How it is capable of putting
the pixels in the right places,
so that they look as a
sky, trees, and buildings?
Is there a representation
that is explicit,
and it contains some
of these objects?
So that's a question
that we asked ourselves,
and we started looking
inside the neural network
to see if it was discovering
some of these objects.
And, indeed, what we
found is that there
are units inside the
network that have learned
to draw a specific object.
For instance, in a particular
layer-- layer number four,
neuron 119--
became a tree-specific unit.
Whenever that unit
was activated, at tree
will appear on the picture.
Another unit-- unit number 43--
whenever that neuron
was activated,
a dome will appear on the
picture, like in these images.
There was another neuron--
neuron 84-- that was
specialized in drawing windows.
Whenever, that
neuron was activated,
a window will appear
on the picture.
And unit 315 was specialized
in throwing chairs.
And whenever that unit
will be activated,
a chair will appear
on the picture.
So what is really interesting
is that these units that
are explaining some objects
appearing or disappearing
on the picture--
now we can intervene
on this neural network
and control what
we want to have on the picture.
So for instance, this image,
which is randomly generated
by the neural network--
if we take the
units that we know
are responsible for drawing
windows and we turn them off.
We tell them not to
get activated anymore
in this picture, and then we
render the resulting image,
what we get is something
like this picture, which is
very similar to the other one.
But it doesn't have windows.
And instead, it has replaced
the window with a wall,
and there seems to be
a painting on the wall.
And the only thing
that we have done
is to manually
turn off the units
that we believe are responsible
for drawing windows.
Here is another example
of a different image that
is drawing a conference room.
If we turn off the window units,
the windows in the background
disappear.
And they get
replaced by diplomas,
which seems to be an appropriate
decoration for a conference
room.
All these images are
completely randomly generated
by this neural network.
We can also ask
the neural network
to do things that
are impossible.
For instance, this
picture is very great,
and we want to have more color.
We can turn on
neurons that we have
found are responsible
for drawing grass.
But we are going to activate
those neurons everywhere
on the picture.
And then the result is
something like this,
where it seems as if humanity
is gone after a thousand years.
And you can see that grass
is growing everywhere.
It's growing on top
of the building.
And these are things that
this neural network never
saw during training.
It's putting objects
in places where
we are asking it to do
it, but this is something
that the network never
saw during training.
So the network seems to have
learned to represent objects
explicitly, despite
that, again, that there
were no human annotations.
No human had to indicate what
the window is, what a car is,
what the grass is.
The network has learned to
associate parts of the network
with specific objects.
So this is part
of this enterprise
of trying to learn
without supervision,
discovering what are
the objects in the world
through different
modalities and imagination,
so that you do not require a
teacher or human annotators
in order to train an
artificial system.
My name is Markus Buehler.
I am the McAfee Professor
of Engineering at MIT,
and today I'll be presenting
some of our recent research
on the Molecular Mechanics
of Unfolding Johann Sebastian
Bach.
We all know Johann Sebastian
Bach as an influential composer
that is still affecting
musical creation to this date,
but have you thought of
Johann Sebastian Bach
as an inventor of new proteins?
As a creator of
new biochemistry?
We have discovered that Bach
might have inadvertently
created, designed, and
realized new forms of life,
new forms of proteins,
new biomaterials
that evolution has
not yet discovered,
but they have been created
through the creation
of musical art.
This provides evidence for
hidden information created
across time-scales, created
across cultural information
levels, to inform science
today, and perhaps
the future of understanding life
on this planet and elsewhere.
When you think
about the formation
of the fundamental
building blocks of life,
you begin to think
about proteins.
Proteins really are the
elementary ancient evolutionary
memories of a very distant past
during which evolution yielded
the kind of life we
have on Earth today
and that emerged over millions
and billions of years.
Proteins spontaneously
come together, or fold,
at very short time-scales,
beginning with time-scales
of 10 to the minus
15 seconds, which
are the scales at which
molecular connections vibrate.
On the other hand, on the
other side of the spectrum,
we have human-created assemblies
of structures, such as music.
Music is an assembly of pitches,
notes, different timbres
of instruments in
complex arrangement,
in complex, hierarchical
arrangements
that span multiple
time and length-scales.
Through the assembly
of notes, we
can induce emotional
responses in our brain.
Through music, we
can convey messages.
Either direct messages,
obvious messages,
or subliminal messages that
are underlying currents
in the musical creation.
With the new tools of
artificial intelligence,
we can now make new
connections and discover
hidden physical
realizations of information
in art to advance science,
humanity, and culture.
There are structural
forms in art
that we believe can
only now be discovered
using modern technologies.
Our research deals with
multi-scale materials.
We look at matter from a
multiple-scale-perspective.
From the atomic scale, where
we have dimensions of 10
to the minus 10
and smaller meters,
which are the scales
of atoms, and orbitals,
and chemical connections.
And we go all the way
up to the macro level,
where we have scales
at the human level
of a couple of meters, or
at the scale of the planet,
many, many thousands of
meters and kilometers,
or to the scale of the universe,
where we have even much
larger length scales.
These materials can be looked
at through this microscope
of different magnifications.
And on each level
of magnification,
we're going to see different
structural features.
These structural features
range from the atomic scale
through the micro/meso scale,
all the way to the macro scale.
And materials derive
their functions--
their unique properties such as
color, mechanical properties,
optical properties,
magnetic properties,
diffusive properties, and any
other kind of technologically
important or culturally
important properties--
through these features across
these different scales.
These are patterns that
humans, in part, have created,
that nature creates all the time
during evolutionary processes.
One of the fundamental
processes we're interested in
is the breaking of materials.
Materials break in
characteristic time-scales
of 10 to the minus 12 seconds.
There's a universality
of vibrations and waves
which occurs at every
observational level
that we have
currently available.
We have molecules which can be
understood based on their wave
particle duality.
Quantum scale objects behave
either as a wave or a particle
simultaneously.
We have sound waves, of course.
That's how we communicate.
That's how animals communicate.
And we have used sounds
in the form of music
as a cultural
expression, as a way
of affecting memory and
passing on information
through generations of cultures.
And of course, we have the
insect world-- spiders, bees,
and wasps all communicate
through vibrations.
With tools we have now available
of artificial intelligence,
molecular dynamics
modeling, we can
map these different time-scales
on a single observational level
and actually make
them understandable
through new processes in
the use of the human brain.
In the beginning
of the universe,
we had a fairly even
distribution of matter.
Small fluctuations
of matter ultimately
led to the creation of planets,
galaxies, and all the things
we have today, including
atoms, of course.
Localization of
information, localization
of energy or matter
which are equivalent,
leads to the creation of
matter as we know it today.
In a very similar
way, when we look
at spiders as an
animal that creates
an extra-organismal
structure, the spider web,
it also does this using
a very similar mechanism.
A spider might eat a fly.
The spider's world consists
of eating things, processing
the things it has eaten
in the body of the spider,
and then reassembling these
building blocks of what
it has eaten into a structure.
From a distribution-- a
random distribution of protein
building blocks that the
spider has digested from eating
a fly--
it can create beautiful
structures, as shown here.
And at the foundation of these
web structures, of course,
are these protein molecules.
And these protein molecules
are made by themselves
from what we call amino acids,
or ultimately encoded by DNA.
And these can be viewed
as a LEGO building block.
So when the spider eats
a fly, it essentially
ingests a very large number
of LEGO building blocks,
and it has a random collection
of these in its body.
And the spider has
found an ingenious way
to then reassemble these
building blocks, these LEGO
building blocks,
into a structure.
To organize them in
space and in time
to create a certain material
function, which in this case,
is the web's function--
one of the functions--
is to catch more prey for
the spider to survive.
Here's the result of an
experimental analysis
where we observe the
spider building a web.
This is work in collaboration
with our cast collaborator,
Tomas Saraceno, with whom
we watched the spider build
a web over a period of days.
And you can see how
the spider is truly
an autonomous 3D printer,
depositing materials in space,
choosing the location,
and thereby creating
a hierarchical structure
that is both aesthetically
beautiful, but also, more
importantly for the spider,
functional.
And in a similar way, when life
emerged billions of years ago--
we're looking now at the
evolutionary time-scales--
we had random processes
and random fluctuations
that created structure.
The basic structure of
the formation of RNA
or other molecules which
ultimately created life
as we know it today, built from
DNA, proteins, and other kinds
of biomolecules.
And this led to the
creation of all sorts
of different organisms,
as we know today.
And again, these organisms have
evolved because ultimately,
at the basic level,
molecules assembled
in particular structure
from a random distribution
of molecules, a barren
landscape that this planet
was billions of years ago
where then suddenly, molecules
began to arrange,
became living objects,
living subjects,
which ultimately
led to the creation of the
human race as we know it today.
Music, in a very similar
way, is an election
of localization of energy.
This election is
created, for example,
through the creative mind or
other processes or animals
which use sound or
music to communicate.
White noise is the
equal distribution
of tonal energy at
all frequencies,
creating a chaotic
and random structure.
And we represent this in our
ear and our brains as noise.
[WHITE NOISE]
This is in stark contrast to
what we identify as harmony,
where instead of having a random
distribution of information
on all frequencies, we now
have a distribution at very
particular frequencies.
By playing tones at very
particular frequencies
or a selection of
frequencies, we
can create musical information,
and encode information,
and create an
impression in our brain
that causes an
emotional response.
[PIANO MUSIC]
Here's an example where I
begin playing white noise
and then use this white noise
as a basis to create sound
that we realize in
our brain as music.
I use the white noise and then
filter out only the harmonics.
These harmonics are
the building blocks
for very simple forms of music.
And you can hear as
the sound progresses
we go from white
noise, filtering out
information and only
localizing energy
at these harmonic frequencies
into a single tone.
We can then play music
in the form of octaves
by using equal
temperament tuning,
and even create
chord progressions
or other, more complex sounds.
And as we turn
the filter off, we
return back to the white noise.
So in this case, we have
created a random structure
and we have localized
information,
we have localized energy and
created what we call music,
or one of the forms of
music that we know as today.
[WHITE NOISE]
[BUZZING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHITE NOISE]
Another way to create music
is to start from silence,
and only create
tones or a sound that
reflects certain types of
frequencies or vibrations.
This is a localization
of frequencies
that we typically use
in the conventional way
of using analog instruments,
like a vibrating string.
These vibrating strings vibrate
at very particular frequencies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We can tune them by changing
the tension or the length
of these strings, and
we can then create music
by having different
types of tuning systems,
and plucking the strings
differently or bowing them
differently.
And of course, an
example for highlighting
the emergence of sound
or music from silence
is the famous piece, 4'33.
The strings don't
have to necessarily
be conventionally tuned.
They don't have to look like
in the guitar, or in a piano,
or perhaps in a violin,
a viola, or cello.
These strings actually
can also come from nature.
And in some recent work,
we have used spiderwebs,
and used the individual strings
in spiderwebs as musical form,
as musical creation process.
And you can imagine that
these strings in a spiderweb
are not tuned according to
any of the tuning system
we're usually familiar with.
In fact they're
tuned by the spider
to follow certain rules and
laws that the spider uses
to communicate, but we
can make them audible.
And what you hear
in the background
is an example of how these
types of vibrations sound like.
It's a strange
world, but you can
begin to live in the
world of the spider
and engage in the
process of feeling
a little bit like
a spider.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Music changes the
state of mind and it
has affected our physicality.
So when you listen to
music, when you hear sounds,
you have a response
in your brain.
It's a physical, real response.
Things are changing
in your brain.
Things are changing.
Material changes are happening
as you listen to music.
Before and after is different.
Our question now is, can
these material changes
yield actual new material form?
Instead of changing our brain--
state of the molecules in
our brain, the chemicals
in our brain, the
cells, the neurons--
can we utilize music as a way
of creating new material form,
or perhaps new life forms?
For example, can we
create new biomaterials?
Can we create new
types of cells?
Can we create new proteins?
This has been the
topic of my research
in the last couple of years.
And we asked the
question, how can we
bring resonances and motions
from the distant past--
perhaps from composers that
have composed music, created
music hundreds, maybe
even thousands of years
ago-- to the future?
And how can we analyze them,
understand them, and actually
use them to create new kinds
of material expressions
and extract information
that's not obvious--
subliminal information
that's hidden
in the musical structure?
We can use this approach to
better understand materials.
We can use it to define
new musical forms,
as a new way of composing
music, of creating music.
And we can also learn
about ourselves,
because this music
is created by humans.
And by studying
what humans create
and what hidden messages
we might be sending,
we can communicate
across generations.
So again, you have a
multitude of length-scales
and time-scales involved
here in this process.
Proteins are the
hardware of life,
and introduction of
proteins essentially
begins with the level of DNA.
DNA is essentially
the coding structure.
It's elementary to
understand how life is built.
It's the building plan for that.
DNA encodes the way
proteins are actually
physically constructed, how
the amino acids in proteins
are put together.
The protein folds
at these micro-millisecond
time-scales to form,
ultimately, living subjects.
And these living
subjects have functions.
They form, perhaps,
cells in a body.
They form organisms, organs.
That can form tissues--
our skin, you can
think about your eyes.
All of these things are really,
truly, made from proteins.
So proteins are the workhorse,
the actual materialization
of life.
And in the evolution, this
plays a very important role.
Proteins are
evolving, of course,
through genetic mutations,
through natural selection,
and these processes lead
to different life forms.
So all these
different life forms
have different
kinds of proteins.
Some proteins have survived
evolutionary processes,
and are found across
different species.
Other types of protein molecules
are only found in one species,
and maybe in one particular
niche, ecologically.
Now, how do proteins look like?
When you open the
textbook and you
look into molecular
structures, you're
going to find a
picture like this.
And you're going to find
a chemical structure--
usually out of water molecules,
maybe some metal ions--
and really reflecting a
complex folded geometry,
and thereby deriving
chemical, biochemical,
and evolutionary functions.
But if you think about proteins
and molecules in general,
that's really not
how they look like.
If you take a real
microscope and you
watch the molecular motions,
which now we can actually
image experimentally,
you can see
that these atoms and molecules
are actually continuously
moving and vibrating.
As these molecules
continuously vibrate and move,
they follow equations of
motions which ultimately are
governed by quantum chemistry.
These quantum
chemical laws can be
implemented in an algorithm
called molecular dynamics.
And we can actually watch,
simulate, and observe
the motions of these molecules.
These vibrations happen
on the scale of 10
to the minus 15
seconds and higher.
So these are very,
very short time-scales
compared to the scale of
observation of the human mind,
for instance.
And if you look at a
simulation of a protein--
this is an alpha
helical protein--
you can see that these
vibrations, jittering motions,
are quite interesting, quite
beautiful, very elegant.
And you can see they have
certain patterns with them.
And these patterns
are associated
with certain
structural features.
We can distinguish
different kinds of proteins
by watching different kinds
of features or patterns
emerge at these very,
very short time-scales.
Now, these
vibrational signatures
are the elementary
description of life.
Proteins are made from 20
naturally-occurring amino
acids.
And each of these 20 amino
acids, we've discovered,
has a unique
vibrational signature.
They vibrate in different
forms, in different ways.
And these vibrational
signatures are
sort of bar codes for
the elementary building
blocks of life.
And this represents a
localization of energy.
Just as we talked about
it during the creation
of the universe a
very long time ago,
during the emergence of life,
during the creation of music
through the human creative
mind, in all of these processes
there's a common
thread, a common theme
that we localize structure.
We put things in
a certain place.
We move things at
the other place,
or we don't even put them
there at the beginning.
And thereby, we create a
distribution, a patterning.
And the way life emerges
is creating patterns
across these 20 amino acids.
Now, these 20 amino acids
can be made audible.
This information is stored
at very high frequencies,
and naturally, we
cannot hear them.
Our auditory system can only
hear up to about 20 kilohertz.
We can solve this
problem by using
the concept of transposition,
or transpositional equivalence.
As this simple
example shows, I'm
beginning to play a melody
in the beginning at very
high frequencies, and
I'm slowly moving down.
I'm transposing
this piece of music
into lower and lower frequencies
until it becomes audible.
So as you listen, pay close
attention and see at what point
you actually recognize
what melody I'm playing.
[TONES SOUNDING]
[MUSIC - BEETHOVEN, "FUR ELISE"]
Once you have recognized the
melody, I'm playing it again.
I'm transposing it again
to lower frequencies.
And to your ear,
to your brain, you
can clearly still identify that
this is the same melody-- it's
Fur Elise by Beethoven.
However, I'm playing it
at yet lower frequencies.
And this is what we call
transpositional equivalence.
We can play melodies at
different frequency levels
by keeping the ratios, the
multipliers of frequencies,
the same.
And thereby, we retain
musical information
or structural information that
is elementary to understanding,
through the auditory system in
our brain, what kind of sound
has been created
and what that means
for our processing in the brain.
In a similar way, we can use
this to translate proteins
into audible spectrum.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And what you hear
in the background
now are all these 20
amino acid building
blocks played in a
succession, and you
can hear that each of these
20 amino acids building blocks
has a unique tone
associated with it.
It's kind of like having its
own key on a keyboard or piano.
However, this is
not a typical piano
because the tuning
system, of course, now,
is a different one.
It's a distinct tuning system
that we call the amino acid
scale.
It follows the quantum
mechanical laws
by which these 20
naturally-occurring amino acids
actually vibrate.
We can thereby map
proteins to sound.
What you hear in
this example here
is the mapping of a
protein called lysozyme.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's an enzyme that's been
studied for many decades.
This protein has been translated
now through this process
into a musical piece.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this process, we also
recognize the folding
of molecules by playing
melodies against each other,
creating a sort of counterpoint
emergence, a counterpoint
function that is very similar,
for example, to Brian Eno's
work using tapes.
So these tapes, you can imagine,
are the amino acid or DNA
sequences that are folded
on top of one another,
thereby forming more complex
musical form than just
the sequence.
And we also
incorporate, of course,
higher-level
structural information
such as the vibrations at higher
length-scales and time-scales,
as well as secondary structures.
These are the distinctions
between an alpha helix or beta
helix.
Each of these have unique
auditory signatures
which can be made audible.
So we're creating a symphony
of auditory information
that encodes the
three-dimensional structure
of a protein from the very basic
level of amino acid sequences
all the way to the
structural, the folding scale.
And this can be applied not
only to the amino acid scale,
we can actually approximate
the amino acid scale using
conventional tuning systems
such as equal temperament tuning
and convert these types of
protein sounds, these kinds
of protein music, into a form
of Western classical music
and play them
using an orchestra.
And we've done this
recently in a piece where
we have sonified the antibody
to the COVID-19 pathogen that
forms when you take a vaccine,
or that forms when you are
naturally ill from this virus.
Your body produces
these antibodies
which interact
with the virus, and
these vibrational
interactions, this system
of vibrating atoms and molecules
that interact with the virus,
with the antibody
trying to defeat it,
is what you hear in the
following example, which
is set in a classical
score reflecting
the information in this
particular protein system.
This piece has been
played by the Lindenbaum
Orchestra in Korea.
We have realized this in
an orchestral setting.
[MUSIC - LINDENBAUM ORCHESTRA,
["PROTEIN ANTIBODY"]
Why are we interested in
translating proteins to music?
Beyond the aesthetic
approach, beyond, maybe,
as an interesting
way of creating
new musical form, creating
new musical competition,
to inspire us to create
interesting musical structures,
we can also use this
to design new proteins.
We can create training sets
for artificial intelligence
algorithms from this process.
Imagine having a large database
of proteins-- thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
proteins-- which we can then
translate into music.
We can let an AI algorithm
listen to all of these proteins
and let the AI
compose new music.
This new music can
then be translated back
into a protein structure.
This approach has
been very successful,
and we have used
this to actually make
new proteins in the lab that
we've designed through music.
I should mention that instead
of having AI create music,
of course, we can also have a
human composer create music,
and write it in
the same form or style
as these proteins produce.
So we can learn these processes.
We can learn the patterns,
the rhythms, the folding,
the interactions, the
counterpoint structures,
and utilize these to
thereby create new proteins.
But using AIs of course,
is a perhaps simpler way
because it's not influenced,
not biased in any way
by the kinds of
musical impressions
that we all have by listening
to all the other music
we've ever heard in our life.
This is the way by
which we translate music
into a new kind of protein
or new kind of material.
We begin this process by
creating a musical score.
These musical scores
include all the information
about the notes, the volume, the
rhythms, and the counterpoint
information as well.
And then we translate
these sequences
into a sequence of
DNA building blocks.
This DNA sequence then
forms the basic instruction
set for cells.
In this case, we've
used E. coli cells
to then express this protein.
Then the cells make the
protein, and we can basically
slice the cell open and
extract the protein,
and purify it, and
put it in a test tube.
And what you see
on the right hand side
is how such a test
tube looks like,
which includes this protein
that was designed purely based
on music.
Now, this protein is a, what
we call, de novo protein.
It doesn't exist in nature.
So through this
musical approach we
have discovered, instead of
using evolution as a way,
over a very long
time-scale, we've
used in a very elegant
way, musical creation
as a way of designing
and realizing
and to form a new protein.
So now we're going
to do an experiment.
Let's listen to the beginning
of the aria in Bach's Goldberg
variation.
And the question is,
what kind of information
is stored in this very
beautiful but very simple
succession of notes, of rhythms?
[MUSIC - ARIA IN BACH'S "GOLDBERG VARIATIONS"
]
And by analyzing this music
that Bach wrote a couple hundred
years ago, we can assign
each of the musical notes
in the aria, the
beginning of the aria,
into a succession of
DNA codes by assigning
unique associations with these
vibrations of amino acids.
This DNA code can then
be formed as a basis
into a protein expression,
just like we've done before,
in an experimental way, by
putting these amino acid
sequences or DNA
sequences into a cell.
In this case, we've put
this into a deep learning
and machine learning algorithm.
These machine
learning algorithms
have the capacity to predict
how these amino acid building
blocks fold, or
assemble, at these micro
to millisecond time-scales
and form a material.
And these algorithms can
also predict, of course,
whether a material
will form or not.
And that's a big
question, because some
of the successions
of notes or rhythms
will not ever form a protein.
There are certain rules by
which these musical creations
in this protein amino
scale must follow.
And the experiment
here is many fold.
One of them is,
did Bach actually
inadvertently create a protein
that can actually be folded
and is stable or not?
And the algorithm has predicted
a very surprising result.
So we used this deep learning
algorithm to fold the protein,
and we discovered that, in fact,
the first 146 notes of the aria
indeed lead to an actual
protein that is stable.
And you see on the right-hand
side how it looks like.
So we went from the
musical form that you
could hear into a
letter of DNA sequences,
protein amino acid sequences,
to ultimately, a protein
structure that we have folded,
and you can now see and watch.
Now, this protein is sort of
the realization of this music.
So I have on this
slide a comparison
of the musical score
on the very left--
the original musical score.
And the right-hand side,
you see the protein.
You can see again
in this example
here that the
protein isn't static.
As I mentioned at
the very beginning,
a protein like this
is continuously
moving and vibrating, right?
So these atoms are
not sitting still.
They are like mini strings--
mini meaning at the scale of
10 to the minus 10 meters,
so very, very tiny strings
or connections between atoms,
the chemical bonds.
They vibrate, and they
have a certain signature--
a certain vibrational signature.
Now what we've done
on this experiment,
we've taken this
protein that we've
created based on
Bach's composition
and translated this
protein again into music.
So the question is, can
we sonify this protein?
Essentially, instead of taking
an existing protein that
evolution has produced as I'd
done before-- the lysozyme,
the enzyme--
we ask, now, the question, can
we convert this protein created
by Bach, inadvertently
of course,
into a new musical structure,
and how would that sound like?
Here we're going to
listen to that piece now.
And what you hear
in this example
is the protein that was folded
based on Bach's Goldberg
Variation aria, the
first 146 notes including
all the information about
how the protein folds,
the secondary structures of
rhythm, of counterpoints.
You can see the counterpoint
map on the right-hand side.
And we can see what kind
of interesting new music
comes out of that process.
[DEEP ARIA PLAYING]
So what this
experiment has shown
is that the music that we have
created has new information.
And the new information has been
added by using a deep learning
algorithm to really
incorporate, truly,
the ancient memory of evolution.
The ancient memory of
evolution is essentially
the building blocks,
the laws, by which
proteins fold from a sequence.
And this folding, this chemical
information, this basic life
information, the living
system information,
has now been incorporated
into this note sequence
that Bach created,
and thereby created
new musical information,
new sound information that
was not there before.
It actually has
created a piece that
is about five minutes
long, in this case.
This new protein is different
from any protein that
has been created by evolution.
In fact, we have
checked this protein
against any known databases of
proteins and it doesn't exist.
So Bach has actually created,
through this process of writing
down notes, new proteins.
We can now make this
protein in a laboratory
and analyze what kind
of function it has.
Now, the function it might
have, it could be an enzyme.
It could be a
structural material.
In other words, it could be
a strong and tough material,
like in hair or fingernails.
It could be a virus.
It could be a pathogen.
It could be a poison.
It could be a hormone protein.
We don't know what it is.
And this is where, of
course, much further research
is needed to understand the
exact function of this protein
encoded by Bach.
[MUSIC, "PROTEIN ENCODED IN BACH'S GOLDBERG
VARIATION"]
But more broadly,
this process has also
enabled us to create a new
way of composing music.
So instead of
writing down notes,
we can write down notes and then
ask a deep learning algorithm
to incorporate new
information, new secret
or hidden information
in this process.
And through this process, we
can incorporate information
across very, very long
time-scales and length-scales,
essentially looking at the
evolutionary time-scales
during which life and all
the proteins have evolved.
And this creates a new
set of musical ideas
that we can utilize, perhaps in
composition or in the writing
of future musical forms.
So there are a couple of things
we have understood, or learned
from this experiment.
One question you could ask, why
isn't the music that comes out
of sonifying the protein that
we have created from Bach
the same as in the beginning?
And the answer is
that, of course,
the folding process has
added new information.
So we have utilized a different
medium, a different expression
of information-- the
quantum chemistry,
the evolutionary time-scales--
and added this information
into the folding, and ultimately
into the listening experience.
And so the music has
changed after the expression
as a protein from
the DNA sequence
that Bach originally invented.
And this is a passage
of information
through a very different
time-scale horizon,
of course, that includes the
vibrations of the atoms which
ultimately make the
sound, the music you hear.
But the memory that we have
incorporated, of course,
comes from a very,
very distant past.
So AI can help us to create
art, or in particular music,
as we've talked about
here in this presentation.
But it really does
not replace humans.
It can be a tool for humans
to become more creative
or to get information and
answers from a distant past.
We like to use proteins as a
way of gaining information,
musical ideas, about
things that have happened
in evolutionary time-scales.
We like to interrogate
proteins and molecules
to see or to hear
what is happening
at the scale of vibrations of
amino acids or between atoms,
and looking at atomic
bonds like a guitar string
that we can excite, and
watch, and hear, and use
as a way of creating
a new scaling system
like the amino acid scale.
But in all of this process,
even though computers and AI
can help us, we still need a
significant input, of course,
and artistic choices
by the human,
especially once we want to
create artistically interesting
or aesthetically pleasing
products that we can process
and understand in our brains.
So the creation
of music is really
a deeply human experience.
It's a way of mapping
out memory of deep time.
And the individual
and collective process
by which music is
created, performed,
improvised, exposed
on, analyzed on,
derived for future
evolutions of musical--
cultural and musical creation.
It's really an
unconscious act to create
consciousness of the past.
And this concept is
artistically very interesting.
It's also scientifically
very interesting.
Because using music as a way
of looking inside ourselves,
to looking at these
distant primordial memories
or structures that
might have happened
during the emergence of
life billions of years
ago, here on this planet,
perhaps even further, deeper
in time, during the emergence of
the universe as a whole, where
quantum fluctuations
have emerged.
And I think this is a
very interesting direction
for research in my lab
to explore whether
these relationships can
be brought out.
Whether we can
make them audible.
Whether we can connect them
mathematically using concepts
like category theory
to other principles
and organization of
information, and thereby
solve of course, ultimately,
an important cultural problem
or scientific problem, or to
advance the ability of humans
to create music and to create
this beautiful abstract form
of art that allows us to
transmit information, emotions,
without ever using
a single word.
So the opportunities
ahead are many fold.
We can see that by looking at
multiple scales in a material
you can watch individual
molecules move.
You can watch
spiders build webs.
We can make spider
webs into instruments.
We can make molecules
into instruments.
We can hear music
everywhere, really.
We can hear the
sound everywhere.
And this tradition, of
course, of using sonification,
or the tradition of
listening to the environment
or understanding how silence,
or the lack of music,
the expectation,
like in 4'33 yields
this particular result of paying
close attention to nature,
close attention to the
environment, is powerful.
And with the tools of
AI, molecular dynamics,
multi-scale experimentation,
microscopes, really--
whether computational
or real microscopes--
we can look inside
materials and understand
a lot of these
principles at a very
deep and foundational level.
And what you're hearing
now in this last example
is music created during
the fracturing process
by analyzing the stress tensor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'd like to thank you very
much for your interest
and for your time.
Please be in touch by email
if you have questions.
Follow me on my
SoundCloud page, where
you can hear a lot of examples
of music created from proteins,
music created from fractures,
and sounds of spider webs.
And of course, you can
also follow me on Twitter
where I post information
about my latest
research on a regular basis.
Thank you very much, and I'll
see you, hopefully, soon,
in the panel.